Sunday night with here at least I added
my girl mr. Pat you [ __ ] want
it there you go you got that's how we
drop it here miss Pat don't [ __ ] around
she got frequent flyer miles a United
planets like a [ __ ] he penis
[ __ ] glasses I work this [ __ ]
ain't no penis I got diabetes really
salty you ain't a waiter penis oh I
thought you say penis great but no no no
I'm a cool mom asawa some also my my
main man Lisa at the flying julik oh
yeah smoking cookie list THC clean ha ha
ha I watched the video back of alpha
robles oh you had my favorite tweet of
probably the century the day when he
went off of people sending you pictures
of hummus oh it's a nightmare I don't
want to see that [ __ ] I don't like I'm
Lucy it's a payback it's karma karma is
a [ __ ] when I was a kid that was
a dude I used to run with he didn't hate
the smell of vinegar he would [ __ ] go
crazy if he's no vinegar what we do we
take a piece of paper vinegar and put
like six different locations in his
office this [ __ ] would come and
go this vinegar in his car he wouldn't
miss work I'm not coming back they send
the [ __ ] clean Lin he would lose his
mind
I was the king of that [ __ ] any handy
cocaine so if we're gonna have vinegar
we get cocaine packages and put like a
fishing line on it and put it in front
of him and like play with it and he
would lose his [ __ ] mind
or put aspirin in and make believe it
was fake and he'd open it up and it
drive him crazy who's doing coke around
here [ __ ] doing coke around here I'll
fire everybody you would about yeah his
name is Wayne means cool mother he
didn't like cocaine and clean vaginas
he's in like cocaine he was a x-bike
tell he was a biker in that he was a
very interesting dude he was a biker in
the wintertime and in the summertime
he'd come back and he'd be a father and
hook up with his wife for six months
deficit they Mountain no he was a
[ __ ] real hardcore biker dog like
with a [ __ ] troop that ran speed
something cuz he made money those six
months he did something those six months
he had to do something leaving and come
back in six months he was white right
yeah we don't give a [ __ ] what color if
I all means going six months you gonna
get a warrant taking out all you child
support of some [ __ ] you got expelled
open come on like a regular job unless
you in jail you got to show up this [ __ ]
for dinner
[ __ ] yeah what's that we miss bad
nothing thank you for having me no
please listen man it was a popular
demand and sometimes you have the people
what they want people always tweet me
once or twice I put this guy on there
whenever once I saw you I'm like that's
my girl we got to put something together
I know you all the way in Indy I
wouldn't send leader follow you in
Atlanta how many I'm in Indy oh you're
an Indian [ __ ] how far from are you in
Indiana I'm right outside about Airport
I always want to go back Michael Jackson
man my god Martha he's very Gary same
[ __ ] a difference no I'm saying no
Garrity kill yo ass you need to pull up
the crime rate this one so bad
I'm never been a Gary all your life
really is a dad I only been in Indy
seven years with my husband job so I
don't go to airport home I don't [ __ ]
windy
okay I mean not the city is very
supportive of what I do I just don't I
don't get around it I want to go home
from Atlanta so that's why I rather be a
manager like he's very nice it's a lot
to do you have been through chocolate
no no Iceland you would swing big dick
and I do you know when I first graduated
college I was thinking about going there
cuz CNN's there
I think cuz I didn't I didn't really
like LA the first time I was here you
was no Ksenia was there now not to get
laid well that's okay he likes
assistants no I do like the sisters I
did right before I moved out here I was
he with
a14 a year and a half and I was gonna
move there he say he's with one yeah
well you can't say [ __ ] son the
battle is sand color girl black yes you
like black women it's I'm Jewish I I
didn't mind I'm getting a Mexican girl
just anything that's different from my
mom basically as far away's [ __ ] you
up you just don't want Jewish woman they
don't mingle well with Jewish women
that's what my daughter said my daughter
is gay yeah he's that any [ __ ] is
different than you so she went I got one
it look like Robin Thicke yeah oh yeah a
white girl yes you got a white girl look
just like Robin Thicke I like it too
it's amazing it's amazing what's going
on in society yeah
my name is Tom and tell your mom 30
years ago that you were gay no but you
know what I think it's something in the
water these days when your child is gay
they drink it in they just glow like
pink I'm gay cuz I know my daughter's
gay a long [ __ ] time yeah you can you
can tell how I was gay when she was gay
how old did you know how old was
probably about 11 10 or 11
cuz everybody else you know I raised my
sister Keith so everybody else was
trying to get [ __ ] she was trying to
read a book some way why aren't she
trying to get [ __ ] I don't love him
well I was [ __ ] at 11 but you know
how girls start to feel they sales is
real they sailed you don't like him boy
she's never had that interest so we kind
of knew she was gay
plus my mother-in-law who's really
really Christian she said she told me
one day she was like we was over our
house for a cookout she's like his child
got a gay beard on I was like [ __ ] you
what the [ __ ] is a nice beard but she
was right he she was right
yeah but she's happy so whatever make
you happy you know kids in cliques make
you happy
eat the click [ __ ] it let's lick that
[ __ ]
hey ma boo saw we're so [ __ ] up is
gone we look just alike and honey like
why don't you be doing that to my face
I presume on my face of Zeebo please
because I see my puss in my 15 years old
well my my face on her bottom seam up
was it did anything but she liked making
it she lost her teeth behind bad place
and she got him seats so now she got a
great teaching take him out do a thing
you're right yes I'm fine you bought no
I'm just teeing up these medical
marijuana cookies that we don't like
well it's cuz they [ __ ] him everybody
else has a little bit he just you don't
you don't listen the doses it be like if
you took the entire bottle of vicodin
after a surgery just something like took
the entire bottle I take you can't give
him that kind of stuff doesn't miss I
don't give I can I give him medical
marijuana he loves it who you kiddin me
giggles and [ __ ]
I see who's giggling stupid [ __ ]
jokes or whatever clean up to a child
now at 16 and 140 yeah yeah two at home
they know what you do yeah they know
what they're doing every moment of it
yeah cuz I'd be out talking about their
fat asses you don't talk about Jackie
let's talk about Mikey's [ __ ] 17
months old toy what may I say about this
you [ __ ] knows this happened she is a
[ __ ] sandwich oh well oh you just had
a baby
51 yeah why are you waiting so [ __ ]
well you supposed to do that in
elementary school and get it out the way
since you know 2099
oh nothing never happened three years
ago boom she got pregnant
[ __ ] how does he is 44 now she was 42
and we're happy for the thing about the
closed-down she kept praying holy [ __ ] I
know she had to be pissed off no she's
she's a different woman is this the
first baby for her yeah oh yeah people
happy about their first shine [ __ ]
heaven she's a different woman oh yeah
I'm gonna do it again I'm 51 I can't be
I got to do other things right now I can
take care of it you can barely have sex
though you can barely get somebody
pregnant I don't want to get nobody
frankly you know that's it this is a lot
of work at 51 dog yeah cuz you don't
have the patient to hear that [ __ ]
around you how I [ __ ] the [ __ ] up but
you can't say [ __ ] the [ __ ]
cuz I just moved my niece in with her
four kids she was homeless and she got
babies and I got a big-ass house where
I'm used to pees and these kids run
around want to talk get the [ __ ] out my
office little [ __ ] you and I forgot I
never moved in [ __ ] talk to you
[ __ ] kids in the - yo she got a
two-year-old she can't talk [ __ ] but
for some reason the - yo keep calling me
uncle gear I'm like [ __ ] I'm a girl I'm
not a [ __ ] uncle gear [ __ ] out of
your [ __ ] baby look like gonna be a
steady real muscular like a little boy
we had to get my ears pierced cuz
they're back up like she was a [ __ ]
boy with a pink shirt on how many kids
you had the house six right now yes the
home is hers in two of them Peter bed
and you know you're like look at him
over gotta stop it but thank God my
daddy died a couple years ago he left
his hospital bed and I was gonna throw
it away but in the back of my mind oh no
my mom was like somebody's gonna come to
pissed on this bed and everybody there
wearing that damn plastic metric out so
I got six kids I doubt that Mikey is
handled because they used to having the
whole house when I was like six thousand
square feet and I gotta share these with
these four kids but they was a homeless
and I tell my kids be grateful that you
know we can help somebody but it ain't
easy cuz it baby be hauling in my knees
be having this [ __ ] put on info to get
away from her own kids she only twenty
three or four kids
oh yeah Nichols myself nobody fixing my
nobody feels sorry for me
well nobody feels sorry you so [ __ ] your
legs in the air [ __ ] did you after -
maybe you was thinking maybe I could
afford this [ __ ] maybe after one but you
had fun [ __ ] you had four [ __ ]
babies then what somebody smells feel
sorry for you what get a job but you got
a job at miles come on play that [ __ ]
let me ask you something how crazy like
years ago I've heard women at comedy
show go they the born-again virgins or
they're holding not to have sex or
they're virgins it's a big thing when I
was a caribou [ __ ] at 12 me [ __ ]
that neighborhood in Jersey they were
[ __ ] I was 12 how was I even I didn't
believe you were 12 when he was 22
yeah that was child molestation today
back then it was somebody happened to
mom out I should just walk in somewhere
yeah what our computer for Christmas
never married he wasn't married his wife
was pregnant and she gave she gave birth
date in August I'm sorry in November
Jamie and I gave birth day in August and
nobody questioned this [ __ ] about
getting these girl pregnant
nobody some good sex now I hope I can
say that because don't know why mr. [ __ ]
some good things back in the day cuz of
course you don't really know what your
dick healing when you only had one dick
at the time then when you get muscle
dick he realized that first dig one all
right you know it was just so you know
[ __ ] no unemployed these delicious I
said it all it's like Obamacare II don't
work but it's good 12 years old he was
22 he was 23 nobody said day oh I had a
second baby bad nobody said dick where
is he today but he almost your age you I
think you got about one year this year
and you still talking I think that was
only just call me every now and then I
said talk to the [ __ ] just took out a
one on my
daughter cuz his stepdaughter ran away
with my daughter [ __ ] ass and I don't
know just some old drum machine that's
what he do he work at Jeffy a little bit
of land if you ever need a hook-up on
the oil change [ __ ] man that's [ __ ]
crazy had two kids buying dinner later
on I got a pregnant again I had an
abortion
cuz I fit I was like this [ __ ]
just gonna keep on punching me in my
left eye on Friday giving me pregnant
and not showing up for nine months so I
was like I can't keep having babies
about this piece of [ __ ] what do you
think like when like I can't imagine now
at 25 I'm feeling I'm too young like
what 12 what are you 13
but how could he like sick like think
about taking care of one I can't even
imagine
I think wouldn't you have mom that
[ __ ] it just kicks in hey I'm a mom I
got a responsibility if you'll give me
of you carry the thing about the kids so
you start that you start your survival
mode
so that's what I did I started my
survival mode and I went to got my first
judge made a fake ID and when I worked
at the haunted house it's like that it's
like the UH wife at the Waffle House it
used to be called a haunted house back
in it maybe for a while where was this
in Georgia Georgia so I worked there and
that's how I bought pampers geez how
much were you making there like four
dollars an hour it was like two dollars
and ten cents an hour but you got tips
and then I've always stolen every job I
ever had
so you know by the time you say hey my
forgive me find out for this meal and
then you throw the ticket away so it's a
hostel it was a hostel as I took
terrible
it's amazing how I don't know I don't
know what how I'm [ __ ] trade you know
I can't fix in that condition I can
paint the wall if I have to I can't fix
a computer
well I can also I can also and hustle is
the is the most it's [ __ ] crazy it's
[ __ ] crazy cuz everybody can't you
awesome because awesome you know I look
at the comedy game like the drug
building game cuz I you saw a crowd
that's how I do it that's it yes are you
cuz if you put it in your mind you
really want to lock down this situation
you're gonna [ __ ] work hard and I
just applied all of my dope-dealing
skills only skill I don't use in comedy
it's turning cocaine and crack that's
the only skill I don't use other than
that I use everything else just a
hustler getting out there doing what you
got to do busting your ass it's the same
thing just waking up in the morning not
knowing not knowing scary is that
opening up your eyes and going I saved a
half a juice from last night I got a
half a joy I got $2 yep tonight's
Thursday that means I got show grandma
blow I got to do this I do that I do
this and that's it you just go out and
it's like treasure hunting yeah it's
like [ __ ] treasure but the good thing
about mines I have a trap you know what
that is was like well you stand on the
corn this that was my corner which
unfortunately it was in front of my
daughter school but Dad that was my trap
so I could go there every day I ain't
like cranky is locked in okay all right
that's yeah no I didn't have I didn't do
the crack part but I went to a place
where everything went down so somebody
will come and three do to be drinking
and then one dude will come on a Mingo
dawg
you know we get a [ __ ] gram of coke
right now boom they pay a hundred bucks
cause me a buck 75 from maple I got this
[ __ ] no I did it I real live
crazy yeah Joey you call it kind of fell
into drug deals most of the time seems
like miss Pat was like a drug dealer a
dealer I would go in and out I would go
in and out I did it for six months
straight then I lost every I got out and
then I got arrested the year later but I
knew how to make a quick buck no I did
actually that was my job every day to
get up pick up the crack and like I do
little pick up the drugs on the weekends
stuff them in my kids underwear and
drive back cuz that was a thing
everybody you know you had to hide it
somewhere so you know this one crack
first hit the black community so what
you do you hide me your kids underwear
nobody's [ __ ] with a two-year old
shitty baby you know where were you when
crack him what year was this
I just had my daughter so it was 86 I
was in a lab yeah West a Louisville mo
cuz that 84 is when I went to New York
City but I went to a spot where they had
Reap briefer three they called it the
master mix it ahead green weed tie wheat
and they call it the master mix they put
both of them together and I went back
like February of 85 I said where's the
weed they looked at me like what the
saint of wheat blocking on was
straight-up crack I didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were talking about I'm like
what's crap and they showed it to me if
I would just ride my bike now so we
never did the vowels in Atlanta we did
those little plastic bags and we just
you know I learned I mean when I first
started my kids father used to sell it
and I just thought he was some [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] ro I was like I can do this [ __ ]
better than you so I went out and I got
a friend from my old neighborhood and I
was like he was like you should come
over here to my old neighborhood and
sell crack and I was like well I can get
the dope but you got to show me how to
do it
so he taught me how to cook it how to
cut we was partners for a long time I
had my first hundred thousand dollars at
16 I had no [ __ ] license and I had
about eight cars
I had a learner licence so I would just
give the police in Atlanta few
interesting dollar they let me drive on
my learner's license in the ones that
work that didn't like me I just put a
crackhead I'm gonna passionate aside cuz
you know you could drive with a learner
licence well that's not learning how to
drive through a crack and I want every
[ __ ] thing so I learned from my my
partner on how to cook get it we ran a
business wheels making like ten thousand
fifteen thousand dollars a day I was 15
years old
15 years old and uh but my kid's father
used to beat on me all the time a lot
like he shot me in the back of the hand
he's just beat on me and he was like
this is bad business him jumping on you
you call the ponies and ponies no you
rabbit because that was my drug-dealing
night seems like that's just bad
business so we split our money we went
our separate ways so he stayed up at the
top of the hill and I moved it to my at
the bottom of the hill because my kid's
father used to cheat all the time
he would take my money and buy my money
and take these [ __ ] and winding down
I'll show up somewhere he got this [ __ ]
my car with my g-ronn so I'm choking
this [ __ ] out he pull off and leave us
fight like you gonna leave your hoe and
me you ain't gonna help neither one of
us so I used to kissing like that all
the time spending my money on hoes I go
over I was just track his ass down for
GPS and was even now cuz he seems so
stupid he was sleeping saving certain
places I got one time I caught him in a
bed with three [ __ ] at sixteen what
the [ __ ] were you thinking at that time
you woke up in the morning and you had
cash and you had your corner what the
[ __ ] were you thinking and you had the
two kids I had two key to his 16th
survivor I was thinking you know they
catch you you lose your [ __ ] kids
right he's going I'm no did not my kids
I had too many people when you got money
you got good friends and bad friends so
when I when I finally did time I had
somebody there to keep my kids so you
know they never you know cuz what it was
is that I had my niece my three nieces
which is all my kid's father nice so I
taught them how to sell Craig and then I
had my cousin
her name was boot I taught her how to
sell crack so I let the kids have
another crack because we was [ __ ] all
kids cuz everybody thought I was grown
really I was [ __ ] 15 years old
running the whole block you just said
went one day was something I was like
how old are you and I was like 15 is
like [ __ ] we're gonna saying mister you
and you our age we know we they couldn't
like nobody could lose a bunch of
[ __ ] juveniles selling dope but I act
so grown cuz I had my first part minute
36 14 I don't make me so [ __ ] fake
I'd be walking a [ __ ] tall like
I'm grown with a baby who the [ __ ] are
you who how you gonna tell me I'm not 21
it's amazing maybe your spirit was 21 my
spirit was okay cuz I was thinking about
that I was following a friend of mine a
couple weeks ago they said how's your
daughter and she was you know she stays
in every [ __ ] night we were out all
the time we were 18
this girl goes one two nights a week she
stays out till 11 with a girl
I got no problem with that but [ __ ]
we're out every night and I was thinking
about we was 16 we were going out
because in Jersey was 18 it was 18 so
it's 16 15 you were already out cuz you
look [ __ ] 18 once you got 15
I don't know how [ __ ] old you are
it's how you walked in there how you
held yourself up you know at 15 and 16
when I'm we didn't have idea to give
beer everybody was Simeon cuz I had
really big titties so they were like
rabbit you going about it because you do
looking [ __ ] so I would always go in
the store and ain't knowing we were in
the hood if you look back in the hos--
Danny the bank knows that you can walk
to the store and buy your mom a
cigarette and the people I ok this round
nobody gave ya buy a six-pack of beer
and [ __ ] you know you wouldn't even
think about it what do you think about
everybody else looks like he's your man
that [ __ ] lis going for the storm girl
my mom sent me I mean two packs of
Marlboros and we get two bottles of
scotch rolling papers yeah the channel I
grew up they card for dear old so it's
just I can't this is boring this is all
foreign to me so I'm just like I'm my
mouth why don't I get like four people
listening like if you two are perfect
together but everyone who's listening
doesn't relate to this at all another
one of my baby-daddy shout you me in the
back of head you're like yeah I got that
you're 16 you're selling crack like what
I can't even it's just I mean like
because when it black when the drug hit
the black mute I tell you the first time
I ever came into heroin I can't say that
drug for [ __ ] heroin or whatever your
[ __ ] you call it anyway
my my my mama's shot up her whole life
I'm on a shot of diabetic medication so
I was familiar with needles but when we
moved into this community that's when
heroin just hit the black community and
here was this um I hadn't had a baby yet
so I was exposed to heroin before a
minute
no it was I was pregnant so I was
probably 85 85 cousin itchy I was
exposed to crack so it was this Atlanta
job yeah and Atlanta Georgia oven it's
called the Weston so at that time heroin
in
crack was in the communal but people was
doing I guess they were spear men with
heroin
so my next-door neighbor would go and
shoot the [ __ ] and I'm not lying
he would get butt-ass naked and I'm
sitting on the back porch and nobody
would say [ __ ] he will run over to me
I'm pregnant with my [ __ ] first child
and just bent his ass over my face be
like rabbit get the rent out of my ass
and I will be looking up his ass like
Jay Baer ain't no rat in your ass your
diabetes messing up because I tell he
had diabetes like my mama and I was like
the red hanging in the front get him
[ __ ] get him okay that's what I
thought he had and he fought every til
we got used to it
it was nothing to see J bear running
around naked telling people to get the
red out his ass on the weekend in front
of the kids nobody's heroin he was
shooting heroin he was shooting there
and every time he do I used to love to
see him do cuz there's nothing nothing
like a black man with a real small penis
good [ __ ] drew his dick up like super
small and he would be out there sitting
on the car with his ass spread-eagle
like somebody about to [ __ ] him in the
bunk the kids would be standing right
he'll be like his ass Oh dirty that's
the first time I ever seen somebody run
a train on a woman when women started
getting on crack and they would come to
the crack house and they would get
[ __ ]
so we pit I'm pregnant we pick it
through the house we pick him through
the wonder of the crack house this is
before I ever saw a drunk drugs and he's
pretty white lady came over and she's
sucking dicks [ __ ] everybody and we
just watch it and they'll [ __ ] her
way up you know the sandwich bags they
didn't have coming so everything that
put no sandwich back zip lock bag and
they're running a train on that's how
bad was [ __ ] crack did you see it
what the [ __ ] would make people it make
you know what it may eat really tired
you know nothing about it I knew nothing
about Oh Craig told him thank you
and 89 now and 90 I came back to New
York after six years of being gone in
Colorado hidden in the mountains Michael
in New York and I go why do you get to
blow me but you gotta go to Yankee
Stadium and I wanted to Yankee Sam I
made the wrong [ __ ] left and right
man
and I ran into crack though where you
actually get out and stab but stepped on
that the vials were everywhere it was
[ __ ] cracking it was like as I was
like was a zombie it was like that show
whatever they [ __ ] call it good you
know black woman was beautiful and that
[ __ ] made them that's why I never use
cray because when they hit our community
now those women started turning ugly I
know what I look like without hair
makeup so if I smoke this [ __ ] and not
comb my hair
I don't think I'm from the [ __ ] zoo
song it's like this digital game for me
you know I mean 25 your white kids
losses would do then 19 whatever Julian
19 somewhere on there yeah jeez what'd
you do to you 19 you backed off yeah I
mean I'd get other stuff before them but
yeah percent of the stuff [ __ ]
you gave [ __ ] I didn't give them I
got the new size do you think some high
school girl yeah you pay if I owe ya
might know did she suck you do these two
no oh one one girl but my nipple now is
that was terrible that was the one I
hear you man yeah I can lip when we went
[ __ ] nuts he was read the phase he
was angered it hurt is he busy like been
at heart in it like it wasn't [ __ ] a
Craigie knows it was a [ __ ] online
dating uh was the worst but no crack was
something that uh Jesus [ __ ] Christ
when as they broke it up until I could
crack me but I mean you made the left
down to that hmm you could feel the
energy it was like being a [ __ ]
horror movie yeah it was like being in
the Thriller video and then when you
left it I smoked crack I smoked crack
for a couple months right
in California never smoked it before I'm
the way home from the comedy story
tonight I would drive on this one street
I'd see these guys in the corner and one
that I just pulled up I know but I
couldn't get coke when I go what do you
guys got me go we got what happened I
don't give me a 20 and they gave it to
me I went home and I tried to cut it up
in the store and it burnt my [ __ ]
nose tell us why that's not you know
that's fine crack guy so I have about
the house so one night when I rather
like coke guys got coke can open love
when I started smoking [ __ ] crack I
smoked crack you smoked it on the Canyon
High Camp yeah my brother used to smoke
it on a high smoke that I smoked crack
for about maybe six months and then I
went to El Paso Texas for two weeks and
this had a bead yeah 99 mm and I was no
Paso for those two reasons no crack I
snorted coke so I stopped smoking why
not just do coke I don't know it was the
craziest thing why don't crack like this
like why did it become popular because
segregating crack is for black people
coke is for white people but you make
crack with coke right yeah yeah but
here's what happened
dad I'm sorry I'm just like why cuz you
always say the thing like mottling why
do I have to add stuff to my weed like
why not just do the coke like if if the
if the drug dealers would get coke to
make crackling why even waste their time
because the crack was cheaper yeah you
gotta fight allas you got something if I
go to a place to get powder for $5 I get
a half a line yeah and you could add to
it like you could take crack when you
cook it and it was this thing called
come back you remember that yes and it
takes just a little bit and blow that
[ __ ] up to a lot so as a drug dealer
you will be making like say if he was
cooking a half an ounce you can turn in
half an ounce of powder into a whole
ounce so where you all's gonna make $500
now you can make $1,000 but she's
probably only spent three or $400
so that's [ __ ] great profit if you
know math and when you went to prison
did you sell it there cuz no I you know
what I know I didn't do drugs so no I
know you do but I don't know if like
because I know you guys probably didn't
watch it but orange is the new black
that watch
me my husband watching the [ __ ] out of
it it came out this weekend and they're
the new thing the season is there's a
new person in the show who's selling
drugs in the prison and you didn't
really do drugs in prison right he
smokes weed a little bit but I have acid
some hippie had acid the head the speed
yeah
they had drugs that had heroin coke
stuff like I did heroin one time I
didn't do the white heroine I did the
Mexican heroin and I did the crank once
or twice in that and I didn't do any
folk good man smoke weed and did you I
never did any drugs but your whole life
my mama was an alcoholic and I don't
even smoke cigarettes and I used to look
at my mom and say everything you do
[ __ ] I never do I didn't say that - cuz
you said it's a black mom you get [ __ ]
up you can curse out in your mind all
you want to but you want curse tonight
in person no no so but everything she
did like she smoked weed mhm and she got
high all the time she did alcohol so I
did none of that [ __ ] now my sister did
my sisters do every time she just got
out of jail so this the first time in
our whole life that I've known her that
she's drug free it's funny because what
happened was they they it's supposed
like the CIA brought into LA whatever
the [ __ ] the same Ricky Ross Broadway
Ricky Ross but then it became this
epidemic across the country that's a
great question Lee because he was 50
bucks
you know cocaine came out it was 100
bucks a gram that's it 50 for a half
gram no negotiation so it's kind of like
when you can see like you cut cocaine
crack is like a super cutting it's super
cutting it but it is so strong it's
still strong because they they magnify
it to the most powerful [ __ ]
source known to mankind but then what
happened was the biggest problem like in
mid eighties was when the Bush
administration was the Bush
administration they were having a hard
time smuggling ether into Colombia and
ether is what you used to wash the
cocaine it's what you washed it and when
you do cocaine at the enemies
and then you get that little draw in
your throat that's why you do the blow
because of that taste you can never
report that taste is delicious you do
that at the end that's why people do
that [ __ ] that thing right there yeah
that's the [ __ ] money shot right
there that's like convert somebody's
[ __ ]
you understand me when somebody's blown
a balloon in your [ __ ] that's what
that first wine
yeah that first we how you going Joe you
want to learn this [ __ ] I just gotta
love this [ __ ] black dude on the
corner I know that first gagger that
determines your evening yeah that
[ __ ] right there is the money
shot that first one and after that it's
it's every man on its own so what
happened was that paste went away they
had a smoke they were washing it with
gasoline oh I remember that [ __ ] I was
getting it from some Cubans in Atlanta
and s mother and everybody was bringing
it back this tastes like gasoline [ __ ]
unleaded is all safe yeah so what they
did was they just burnt it down you just
taste it now you taste the guys's bright
what nine ounces of this cat piss that
was tremendous it [ __ ] you up but it
smelt like [ __ ] pure cat piss
it was in a cat ass I don't know until
this day I don't know I went over there
the guy always that goop coke I took it
without sniffing it I went home I did
two lines I'm like this taster then it
started tasting like cheese there was a
bachelor start tasting like cheese oh
because they were war they ran out of
[ __ ] to wash it with me about watching
because I don't know
you know when they take it and they
[ __ ] get the leaves and they [ __ ]
put a little Indian I stepped on it
alone takes the extract mixes it with
powder that becomes a clay they lets it
sit overnight for [ __ ] 92 hours that
whole process see I didn't know they
process oh it tasted a very [ __ ]
weird so it was just
but before cry like the cocaine came out
then in 81 82 was
freebase yeah and that was a complete
different thing that's what
watch with baking soda and you have to
come back there and that was a [ __ ]
heavy-duty white [ __ ] that was they
people with with English accents with
doing that him saying wait and what was
your friend doing when he walked wrong
with a microwave
what was he making bazookas there that's
a complete that's another form also oh
geez where you take a gram of coke put a
2/10 of baking soda and put in the
microwave oven oh yeah and then you
bring it for 30 seconds it comes out in
a rock you shaved that [ __ ] you
put in a cigarette okay
or a [ __ ] face the column ah these
are called heat John D joints bazookas
[ __ ] you're going to turn and peek
over there I feel I want to let you guys
talk most of it but this is all stuff I
have no experience and most people have
no experience oh it's just great it's
like it's a whole new education it's yes
it's [ __ ] crazy and people have
become a millionaire off of crack
because the profit margin hey I put my
first daughter through private school
with current winner crack money will
[ __ ] make you because all I got not
anymore cuz people don't do it no more
we work in a day really don't do people
do you if you say if you build a Dale
come if you put a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hot chick by in-n-out burger and give
her 30s and so for 10 look at this
business going up again looking for a
[ __ ] job we get some hoes out here
someone some crack you'll be back
they'll call you the Jewish [ __ ]
connection oh my god so you had $100,000
at 16 years old 16 years did you ever
get to the point is Joe I mean my
mistake people not knowing what she was
doing and that's a but she wasn't even a
[ __ ] CEO no four years of college no
[ __ ] nothing for you [ __ ] business
majors I got a hot dog stand
you don't know dick okay business is it
listen the biggest gift you can learn in
life is belly-to-belly sales yeah there
ain't nothing like belly-to-belly sales
that goes throughout your [ __ ] life
you know that's why a lot of people jump
off buildings because they don't know
how to handle stress for any reason when
it's failed they want to kill a [ __ ]
sell but for me and you we like [ __ ]
in everything we're gonna start the next
[ __ ] thing the hot dogs we need
to put chillies on the next
[ __ ] soybeans can fail what did you do
you lose it like [ __ ] you I lost it I
mean anything comes for his gold face so
you never heard this man well I have but
I mean most people know Joey story they
had a Laden go so I decided I don't know
yours my mother had a lot not me
well you I mean but you went through
periods like doing The Longest Yard and
then you were addicted so you went
through a lot of money when you think
about it if you didn't spend any of that
money on coke you'd be living in Beverly
Hills right no no but the whole thing
was it was [ __ ] confusing I mean you
know when you when you when you out in
the street you're gonna eventually have
to spend that money either you're gonna
go to jail
my [ __ ] robbed you love a girl try to
kill you that you can't a lot of people
say oh I can get out the beads with this
money what comes fast goes fast I mean
you know and then plus you gotta
remember I was sixteen fifteen sixteen
year old girl with that kind of money
out of it hood what I supposed to do
with it up did like everybody else about
[ __ ] joins cause and now music in
Chinese you know I made money from drugs
on one run in 80 and 85 86 I made money
from drugs even though I was a [ __ ]
coke fiend because the profit margin was
so big people are paying eighteen
hundred an ounce I was getting for 800
an ounce
mm-hmm and putting 10 grams of cutting
that [ __ ] selling it for 1,800
they couldn't go right I couldn't lose
money and I had it sold before I got
that so I went under the bed
I swear to God I started this little
side business and maybe June of 86 and
by August of 86 at sixty thousand under
the bed $50,000 eating stew out every
day that restaurants taking I'm jyler
bomba bomba my [ __ ] November I hold
$40,000 I hold 40,000 hostile local drug
dealers so that's how fast it goes fan
you don't give a [ __ ] when you always
gotta keep us I hustle like before
before crack came along and like I will
go my sister these
guys was coming to the neighborhood and
only white people only came to your
neighborhood if they was the insurance
man or if they wanted to buy [ __ ] so I
was at the time I was really into
wrestling and I was too young to really
sell [ __ ] but my system was selling
[ __ ] so when my sister then wasn't
there I would tell the white man's you
know give me a ride to the wrestling
match because I like wrestling so they
will pay me $100 white eject ad I
watched that's all he wanted me to do so
that was a really good style hustle for
me well they just jerked over he just
watched yeah he was driving me downtown
and dropped me off but he'd be done
jacked his dick all the way there and I
just be he just wanted me to talk to him
and I was probably 11 so I would talk to
him yeah you were hurt that deep white
baby he played me hunt you down I won't
you know I'm for $100 went back in 85 84
when I was going to fly that way yeah
yeah I was like yeah beat it and it
wasn't that big so if I didn't really
pick over I couldn't see oh my god it's
amazing when you're in that world when
you see people's weaknesses and you see
what people will do and it's amazing how
you're raised and how your perception of
people is like you respect people I'll
be you know people creeping
[ __ ] when you see somebody jerk
off and I can't be you have bugs it's
not even [ __ ] but you know what when
I was little when I was really young and
I was in elementary school I remember as
a kid on Friday this dude were riding
around in his car and Jack his dick and
look at the kids and we called him the
ding-a-ling man every Friday we knew the
doodling man was coming and nobody was
scared of dignity man we was telling a
teacher he's like just stay away from
the Dingle a man he didn't want to [ __ ]
nobody just want to look at you and
shoot off what it is called and we would
I go to Diggle a man and when I asked
people I was like y'all don't have no
Dingley May everybody had a ding Lehman
oh if you didn't have money for cookies
you go over to the candy main house and
let me touch that little titty
undeveloped titty okay you can rub it
how many cookies you gonna give me
anything that was making money I mean
you were you was earning
you got I mean yeah that is child
molestation now but it wasn't nothing
for old due to rubble your ass for some
fries pop in my neighborhood and a
dingaling man was guaranteed to be that
every Friday that's [ __ ] it's amazing
how when you grow up you're like you
think everything is normal
yeah I can't and I don't wanna I'm not
none of this judgment but it's just like
growing up I'm trying to think of me me
eleven and I all this stuff you're
saying I can't I don't know if I could
handle it now when I'm there because
your ass was shelter but if you have a
shelter [ __ ] Johanna is it anything you
I have I'm gonna jump off a [ __ ]
bridge so what when you raise your kids
do what you want them to be sheltered or
they were shelter one no dignity man in
my [ __ ] neighborhood if it was
he was gonna get beat down but in a way
it made you who you are so is it a good
thing or a bad thing but it made me
aware of what was going on in the world
that how how I wasn't watched out of
like I was a kid like all the [ __ ] that
happened to me like I got molested and
stuff like that and I was like nobody
never touching my daughter [ __ ] I would
kill them I [ __ ] even if I got
married I had a talk with my daughter
every day I say if my husband ever touch
you I want you to know don't nobody who
walks this earth me more than you and
something you and your brother to me
didn't he do y'all do I killed my father
and I asked my daughter that from the
time I married my husband she was in his
second grade to ninth grade til she told
me can you please stop asking me this I
was like well why you want me to study
if you wanna touch me right now don't
you think I would have told you I said I
just want you to know I go [ __ ] him up
right now so I mean I just I was I
wasn't I wasn't I don't think I was
overprotective but I kept her out
because I knew the signs of a [ __ ]
ding-a-ling man and ice cream man and
the [ __ ] who rub up against your
titties for fries pop you know people
see your weakness and they play off your
[ __ ] weakness you know like my
weakness was I didn't have nobody never
loved me
so this grown-ass do coming act like he
loved me and what did he do he take my
[ __ ] virginity you want you wasn't
getting downtown like that when my
daughter get the [ __ ] away from him I
can buy my daughter her own clothes and
shoes I'm a supportive pan but that's
what happened when you grow up with an
alcoholic parent and nobody's watching
over you [ __ ] watching after they
kids you know it wasn't [ __ ] for us to
be in my granddad and look at house you
know [ __ ] dancing for the grown means
and they looking at us like we [ __ ]
ice cream pop you know there's a freaky
[ __ ] ever but we had to dance form
that's funny cuz they my daughter ran
the park and then she slid on saying
that she bang dad and I was sitting
there thinking about this book I'm
trying to write in the narrative I'm
gonna I was thinking about the now it
would be well I let my daughter go 248
Street now like I grew up in Harlem 48th
Street that's not why I grew up I grew
up laying the age to go out on the
weekends I go do Santeria [ __ ] with some
crazy [ __ ] Cubans that's my godmother
lived I saw a dead body the first time I
just saw all this [ __ ] and I was
thinking to myself what I let my
daughter go up there now if somebody
called me and said hey it's the
summertime saying your daughter in New
York for two weeks to come up and stand
on 48 would I let her go up there and
that was I was just thinking about that
how would I act toward something like
that
do I want a shelter mercy well you can
be honest to him cuz with my kids I used
to say you know I'm not letting you go
around my uncle's on my family cuz the
[ __ ] are crazy like you ain't
nothing like to go to a funeral and a
fight break out I'm serious I mean it
ain't nothing to see a fight break out
at your funeral because somebody mad
over some [ __ ] two years ago you
know first of all my family only get
together when somebody died we don't
have a [ __ ] family reunion when
somebody that we turn it into a family
reunion and a feeling hey I get to see
you [ __ ] all season no more to
somebody else's died you know like I'm
always telling the story about my
granddad when he died you know how
people just came and my cousin em showed
a ass
my granddaddy laying in the casket her
kids beating on my granddaddy and all
kind of crazy [ __ ] so you know is with
me I just tell my family this is my
family but this is this ain't my family
we see thee mother or somebody die would
you do differently when you were raising
your daughter's that you watch them how
much more did you watch them what's the
kind of she I didn't let him go with
people house you could not spend the
night on noble house cuz I don't know
about your dad but I know I don't want
to [ __ ] your friends I don't know I
don't know how crazy they are bring your
friends over here I didn't know I never
let them go over nobody house I never
let I'm just getting calls with people I
pick you up you know I just kept it open
and you know but my daughter was dead
when I sold drugs she was dead when I
when I you know I got shot twice one
time in the head by my kids father
didn't God blew my nip off so my
daughter was there tonight the [ __ ]
bloom a nipple nipple left nipple nipple
yeah he shot me 145 bloom anupam so she
saw all of that [ __ ] how old is she now
she's 28
how's she doing I think that's why she
gay that's the gay one yeah I mean what
do you want your kids to see what don't
you want them to see that's the question
I live with you well I keep it real my
other kids like my daughter my younger
kids they know I dropped out of school
in eighth grade what do you know [ __ ] I
was trying to challenge me cuz she
thinks she's smarter than me like we was
at the dinner table other day and she
was like she come home and telling her
daddy before school ended you know what
she learned in hit history by Hitler and
she looked at me to my mama what you
know about history I said I know three
[ __ ] got killed on the east side [ __ ]
that history do you know how to turn
cocaine into crack because ain't nobody
at this table can do that but me so I'm
the smartest [ __ ] at this table and I
said do you know how to run with a baby
in your hand from the police and not
drop the [ __ ] baby I'm smarter than
you and I constantly tell her they cuz
she look like she'll drop the baby
it's amazing how I have what you have a
have a street I mm-hm
I have a street I so when I'm out I'm
looking at things that you don't even
[ __ ] dream of yeah
I'm looking at [ __ ] that you're not even
looking at I'm looking at and I'm
thinking why is that guy over there I'm
thinking okay I don't think nothing
happy I don't know what the [ __ ] people
are talking about you know I'm always
[ __ ] paying attention I see with my
wife I take my wife to the park with the
kids I want to strangle she's into a
conversation with a woman and the baby
walks five feet walk this way
looking at the [ __ ] kid Paul
telepathically
the [ __ ] you taking your eyes off the
[ __ ] kit for I tell all the time
don't take you kiss me what a
[ __ ] Sanford I turned my back
for a minute what the [ __ ] thing it
was no [ __ ] minute but it was a
minute that's how quick those little
[ __ ] get picked up we'll get
stand a little fall or get you whatever
you know so I come from a different
[ __ ] society I'm oh I'm looking at
completely dish written shut the airport
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] and I think that's
from that street mentality like I don't
want walk into a place I look around at
everything because that's how you get
killed by not [ __ ] paying attention
and I teach I teach my kids look at
[ __ ] the eye because if you
look him in the eye you can um eyes tell
you to store everything the [ __ ]
who gonna kidnap they already know what
they've got to do before they do it but
you look at me my I say [ __ ] what be
today and I kill your [ __ ] that
first of all I'm too heavy for you to
pick up and wrong with me so who your
pills to better work and I just give it
to him in my eyes
don't [ __ ] try me I'm I've elating in
today the day you will be [ __ ] up so
and I tell them on time but you people
walking placing them not paying I pay
attention everybody hates me I don't
know what the [ __ ] in your book bag I
don't know what the [ __ ] you going
through but you're not about to kill me
because you having a bad day like in
Atlanta couple years ago before I was
before I moved to Indy there's no stupid
[ __ ] get over the overpass and
gonna jump off and everybody trying to
pray you know talking there I'm like
what you [ __ ] jump so I can keep going
home you've got traffic blocked up cuz
you having a bad day don't [ __ ] hold
my day up cuz you wants to kill yourself
go to your garage and blow your brains
out
so I mean that's
type of person I am now when you got
shot that what happened break it down
for me I was on oh and I got shot in the
head woman my kid's father shot me in
the head when I got a 70 year old
yeah he's [ __ ] 50 laughs yeah I was
at home I was at my house with a guy he
comes over and want to play like he
bagged he said he didn't mean to shoot
me buddy he hit me with a 38 and that
[ __ ] blow a nice chunk out the back of
my head and then this [ __ ]
didn't stick around and see if I was
gonna die he actually ran off and left
me I woke up and when they called now on
one blood everywhere
I don't know you in the hospital for a
couple of days cuz he's only like crank
my skull it's a nice and big scar back
there so the dollar was like we don't
even know how you alive I said I said I
guess God got a story for me something
for me to do yo shut the nipple off o
something I was arguing with over
[ __ ] cocaine transaction he spit on
my call so I stick the pills in his face
and he come in with an automatic with my
little [ __ ] broken 38 not working
that's what I learned if you wants to
draw a gun somebody gon kill him gonna
kill him don't draw she don't nobody not
using gonna kill his and he came back
and he hit me up on my arm and blew my
nip off let me taste it I'm getting
stressed I just don't see why cuz it
takes me back yeah
I gotta tell you this story I was gonna
write what Lee why are you red in the
face that second because you're talking
okay in the nipple autism guy if I got
shot if I got shot
no in the area of someone getting shot
once I would never leave the house ever
again that's just scary ass I can't even
it's amazing I just do some crazy [ __ ]
come thank you were young you don't
think you can die like I tell you the
time my kid's father was cheating on me
right so I on this guy was in the West E
and I was walking across the oval path
and I just happen to look over the
overpass and this [ __ ] down
that in his car with a [ __ ]
oh my mind is gone left I jumped off the
overpass onto that [ __ ] call
right who is this [ __ ] in the car with
you
you know before the drove off and I fell
off he [ __ ] my leg
he got so Muslim he didn't know that was
me I was like [ __ ] you see me coming
down at the air how the [ __ ] you not
know that was me I was calling your name
in the air what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
do it in your car until I hit the hood
now your new husband what's he thinking
about all this life he's like everybody
always asked him did you shoot in the
chamber service right he was he not
anymore he's a gentleman he's retired
from the service no no no no he just did
his little tournament get the [ __ ] oh no
when when was the day you woke up and
decided that's it um you know what I was
a epidemic cuz even after you say that
City you got that energy around you for
a couple more years yeah I was just
tired I was tired of [ __ ] selling
crack I was I was mean my kids was
headed to where I was headed then I was
like what if I get killed and I got to
get my kids to this [ __ ] ass dude or
what if I go to prison he ain't stay but
he got my feet he got here like 22 kids
at the time so I just started praying I
said look I really need my kids like a
baby a daddy and I went to a comedy club
and I met my husband and I was like he
don't know he just answered this ad I
had in the newspaper they're hiring baby
daddy and I gave him the look up and now
he's very intelligent speaks really well
you know I'm country as [ __ ] so I needed
somebody I could learn from his tennis
shoes was clean and he had his back
teeth I was like BAM you got the job
twenty four years I have two other
children today just two with him many of
my head together and what's he thinking
when did you turn the [ __ ] craziness
walk with Jesus he turned the craze in
his own cuz at the time I was still
selling crack and I was into forging
chicks and [ __ ] and so he was like well
what if would have you something
happened to you you know what about
these kids and he was like you know
who's gonna be together we really got it
you gotta get a job I was like a [ __ ]
job what'd they do that it they don't do
that around here you know I'm used to
going outside writing forging checks and
making some $100 mm I didn't sell my
crackin I'm back
about two o'clock five six thousand
dollars in my pocket but he was an
honest man never been to jail never
committed a crime never had a traffic
ticket and he just I don't know ask some
I was on where the [ __ ] did you stay
with me I was stupid as [ __ ] I get to
fighting at a football game one day and
all we was in an all-white neighborhood
he stopped I would start to get my life
back together the guy struck my son out
now I'm a hood ghetto [ __ ] [ __ ] my
husband told raises voice for Nick I
jump up pregnant with his first child
run out on the football field and push
the [ __ ] out of the Empire no [ __ ] you
gonna let him back one more time that
one like that hit his home and everybody
what the [ __ ] I'm up about five miles
pray not the [ __ ] I say and what about
it have we'd only black people I'm
acting straight [ __ ] my hosts ending
like I can't believe this business hit
this man and they said I ended up date
they ended up issued a warrant for me
and I had to go cuz I got criminal my
criminal background history say all
drugs so I had to go to [ __ ] hate me
for six months
listen to crack eat yeah I'm part of the
thing the probation yes I had to go and
sit listen to crackheads for six miles
pissed
have you been decent decent person
probably 24 years 23 so when I got with
him that [ __ ] was over their life was
gone I was done was it love not at first
cuz I told him I said look I've been
with my kid's father for a long time but
he will beating on me he was cheating on
me
he was [ __ ] veneered is the gonorrhea
crowds fleas all that [ __ ] everything
you have fleas I'm gonna ready to paint
I'm probably really bad I got her brows
Oh crab [ __ ] [ __ ] stink they give you
at [ __ ] the palms in New York my man
spin oh there you have steak with the
[ __ ] crab on top it's only gonna be
able [ __ ] little crab marinara on the
side and you're [ __ ] old Jew he is
turning red [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he
probably got a 5p we have and - i'ma
call his mom he's known a long way
though you know but I started to get my
life at together when he you know my
husband do this and I gave it all up
was it love it was love I love the [ __ ]
outta me I got the best husband never
judge me never said [ __ ] I could cook
you out together don't call me no [ __ ]
first of all about disrespect to me but
you know never disrespect me never put
his hand on me I always been a [ __ ]
straight-up good guy and man when I used
to tell him these horrible stories
he'd never judge you just listen you
think it was God no way that put him in
here yes it had to because I was headed
for death and when you seen him the
first couple ways you like what the [ __ ]
this poor [ __ ] would you know
what him I really wasn't dating him what
happened was he would watch my kid it's
why I go out and for his chicks and I
would tell him I'm gonna bring you some
time of Hilfiger bag so he started off
kind of like as my babysitter I didn't
always get evict it on time cuz I
wouldn't pay my rent cuz I would have
mine I'd be done [ __ ] up you know
[ __ ] went to the club and I was getting
evicting he I was like I kind of found a
way to get me apartment he said I'd get
you up for me I was like for real cuz
that doesn't happen in the hood you know
do a good credit then you don't get no
mail no job and good credit and don't
beat on you and he black she that was a
goal bad it's funny cuz I was [ __ ]
crazy I was [ __ ] crazy Doug
I was going Miami and doing blow I was
coming back and doing spots at the store
and sleeping on Ralphie makes [ __ ]
floor it wanna kill my wife and it was
just a [ __ ] horror show of my life
and one Sunday night I walk into the
comedy store as I'm walking up the
stairs this girl's walking down the
stairs and we just looked and she kept
walking I didn't say nothin and I will
later I went back to the other so know
whatever the [ __ ] I was drink I start
talking it's my wife and we started
talking but three nights later I called
them I got $30 from somewhere and I
called I said you want to do something
let's get coffee we got coffee and smoke
a few cigarettes and and I remember
sitting there sitting across something
all this girls interested in me I can't
believe this
this girl's a Christian girl in
Tennessee see white don't smoke reefer
don't blow don't do drugs or pills never
even knows about it said she had a
roommate in the valley that was didn't
know what she was doing but the spoons
were all black no no she was that
[ __ ] naive and I start dating knowing
that I'm at one time I'm going New York
to do a [ __ ] show and I swear to god
Miss bad I had twenty hours and I'm not
she was a waitress she went like 40
hours I was with her maybe a month and a
half and she says how young it - yep I
have no idea she was do you have any
money I got that like 30 bucks
she gave me four dollars and a half a
pack of cigarettes
and I remember going to the airport
rhyming I'm going I can't believe this
happened to me I gotta love this girl I
gotta like this girl I don't want to
like this girl because I don't deserve
this woman well that's what I kept
thinking of and then we started dating
and hanging out more than [ __ ] one
day I just move in and the whole six
months I'm like this is [ __ ]
craziness if this girl even cooks for me
and ask me about my clothes where are
they that she wants to wash them I just
couldn't [ __ ] believe it man and 12
years later I have a baby with this
[ __ ] kid what woman this I fell to
like when I first got on my husband I
cuz I'm used to a man disrespecting me
and putting his hand on me and treat me
like [ __ ] and cheating on me so when I
got my husband and he wasn't
disrespecting me and putting his hand on
me I would use this card during the day
while he went to work he's worked at
senta's mattress and I remember I would
leave his job just crying oh thank you
lord thank you for such a good man cuz I
mean you know I just I didn't think I
didn't think that was [ __ ] ever happen
I mean so instantly because once I got
rid of there he just popped up out of
nowhere we got close one go before
another one opens yeah but I actually
prayed well I knew I was over him I went
and I got on my knees one day and I said
Lord I've asked you for years it changed
his clown I said but you you won't
listen to me I said so I'm coming to you
sincerely with my heart open I'll [ __ ]
him change me I went to bed I spent with
him that night I slept with him the next
day and I did not have no desire just
like that God turned me off I was no I
had no desire for him after that I
remember I can still see meal and I said
I wish this [ __ ] would get off
me no desire and that was on a Tuesday
that Friday I met my husband went to a
comedy show where'd you get the comedy I
got into comedy um never thought I was
funny
people always been attracted to me so I
I went to the welfare office and I told
you know I would tell these fucked-up
stories about my life you don't have my
baby daddy beat me and my momma was an
alcoholic and I remember telling this
story about my mom used to get drunk all
the time and I say every time she got
drunk she wanted to motivate me and she
would say she like reach for the stars
and I hope you hit the Sun and burn up
this [ __ ] trying to kill me you know
you know be all you could be in the debt
don't work out you can always be a home
but I was eight years old and she was
telling me this [ __ ] so what I did was I
would go to my caseworkers and I would
tell them how horrible my life was and
one day I get this black caseworker and
I tell her all these stories and this
[ __ ] just busts out laughing so I'm
like what are you laughing that she's
got you should be a [ __ ] comedian I
was like ain't
funny about this [ __ ] you like this [ __ ]
is hilarious and I was like really and I
and I went and the first month my first
spot
Oh with a little pull-up please call the
Irish pub and I will go up there every
Monday night just to test it out and the
first time I went up there I could
jungle you know talk about people real
good and it worked out really well they
know the [ __ ] I was doing I was like oh
I'm a comedian how long ago was that 11
years ago
it's my 11 year this year I can make the
strides you [ __ ] them up but it's
funny that you're very fortunate because
you cut through a lot of [ __ ] with
this podcast world there's now these
[ __ ] doesn't get to know where
you're coming from see if they see you
sometimes doing material up on stage
they think that's who you are and they
judge you on that I learned that using
when I watched 24/7 those boxing things
on HBO or in UFC they always show
[ __ ] house they show his wife
so you may have met him you may have not
liked a [ __ ] because the way he
boxed what you got to see his wife and
his kids and how he performs and I
reacted you fell in love with the do
because not even it was struggle yeah
and because of the podcast world because
of the internet now you know when I when
I [ __ ] came up I used to look up to
Richard Pryor I know he loved himself on
fire and I know he was [ __ ] up on
drugs but that was it I didn't know he
have kids
I didn't know buzz personal life I
didn't know what his struggles were
after Jojo dance I found out his mother
was a hooker hey so all the [ __ ] that we
saw growing up that's what gives them a
little bit of the insight that's what
you know you know people like you and I
we saw some [ __ ] and the way to make it
better is by making ourselves laugh yeah
well in that corner of Sandhya's so
Jesus what the [ __ ] I just see I wanna
sign you just make a joke to yourself
and you go to bed and everything's
better yeah I mean I did that many nice
many nice
that's why I shouldn't living in a house
with my grandfather you know doing
bootlegging [ __ ] you answered I mean you
just saw so much [ __ ] like I saw my
granddaddy shoot a [ __ ] about ten times
well I'm standing on the porch she
called him a black man
you know back in them days you don't
call black means no [ __ ] no oh that
was like jealous hey you could have got
away with the inner ear been a white man
but [ __ ] oh hell no they had too much
to prove and they call my grandfather 38
he cared 238 pills in his pocket he was
like a big [ __ ] like a wrestler
yeah hands like [ __ ] a 13 shoot I saw
my granddaddy he'll to do so hard knock
that [ __ ] cross the street and he
called the boss at the same [ __ ] time
and this lady was in there she was
acting the fool I had to be about eight
and he was he drunk the [ __ ] added to
it go home [ __ ] and she liked you black
[ __ ] and he didn't go for that she
shot her finger off he said a gone [ __ ]
I don't shout your finger and she kept
talking he just cut them to pieces I
like rambo top he's saying a [ __ ] you
gonna need an ambulance
so my run outside daddy why you shoot
woman why he like [ __ ] her [ __ ] gonna
pull out the moonshine so I don't get no
moonshine charge don't say this thing
like you a shot this [ __ ] by 12 time
you worried about a moonshine child so
we pulled out and looking [ __ ] and
called 9-1-1 he [ __ ] that lady up so
with nothing to see you know like crazy
[ __ ] like my granddad knocking my [ __ ]
out shooting the [ __ ] pistol
whooping a [ __ ] for drinking is
looking not having his money it's
[ __ ] crazy and that's how you Coplin
oh I got a ticket so I had an uncle
named uncle Cecil he was crippled you
know he two lanes [ __ ] damn near
stuck together so my granddaddy would
buy him [ __ ] I'm sorry
so my granddad would buy that's what
does my granddaddy son he will buy my
uncle Cecil [ __ ] right true story so he
buying [ __ ] he tell a hole he crippled
just let him get some [ __ ]
but my uncle Cecil was Tiger he was a
[ __ ] huh what he smiled all the time
so we the home would let my uncle sister
get on top of it me and my sister had to
go in there and pull my uncle Cecil legs
together until you put his dick in it
I'm not lying to you and I remember one
day he was laughing so hard cause he
would happy everybody get some [ __ ] and
I like [ __ ] stop laughing and stick
your pinky and I want to go play pac-man
hey he what's he getting in and get
started we could leave but we could
leave until he got the Dicky but my gran
had a body puts a lot of time and a
one-nothing like I just bought you see
supposed to go back there hip you
imagine if you told me that today like
out of the bar like three days later you
get a [ __ ] visit from Social Services
you get pounded by your [ __ ] crippled
sons invoker God you could not have get
him a piece of [ __ ] if you see somebody
who's crippled - see that's what they
need after time is a good piece of [ __ ]
he's not being them being crippled is
bad enough now you can't get a piece of
[ __ ] even just a lickin you know what
he did he was a tie he was like really
[ __ ] like he sat on the porch every
day and everybody who went into all
bootleg house he would say [ __ ] like hey
boy give me two nickels to nickels make
a dime let me tell you about this story
if you gave him a dime he will beat the
[ __ ] out of you he didn't like dimes
he liked nickels so if you walk in that
house and [ __ ] run against we die he
will put a chokehold on y'all he didn't
like dives and he didn't like uniformed
police I was come back in the day it was
like the late the late seventies they
won't bow ties so he like whooping on
police's ass
he would call now on one and hang up so
here that rush out to y'all and when he
get there he will beat the [ __ ] out of
him one day he grabbed his white woman
by her bowtie and drug that [ __ ] in the
house and I'm taking my [ __ ] uncle
he would [ __ ] he will pile driving
the [ __ ] out this [ __ ] come back up I
swear I think police was jumping out of
helicopters down on my return it up when
they saw that [ __ ] up like a blanket
so we will go to this danke Caesar if
you had on a uniform he'll beat your ass
so we've literally walked him like a dog
with a chain around his waist cuz he you
had on you he was gonna put you on a
chokehold a man he was mm fighting
before
mm fighting got out and he only ate out
of pies he would not eat out of a plate
I don't know the [ __ ] was going on but
you had to give him a pot with a hand on
it
I don't give a [ __ ] if you serving gravy
biscuit though all that [ __ ] in there
together and that's how he ate he was
scared of place he was a weirdest person
he didn't like dive he didn't like you
and for me he did like please I'm like
soymilk
hummus or [ __ ] whatever this sheep
ranch ranch [ __ ] foster ranch
so we're just as [ __ ] crazy miss Pat
man it's been [ __ ] interesting it's
very interesting that we have similar
backgrounds we saw some [ __ ] and that's
who we are on stage and you know people
respect that'll people don't like us
because it's too [ __ ] real sometimes
you just come across like with a real
you know it's it's just people get
thrown so much [ __ ] now they don't
even know what's real and what's fake
any [ __ ] moment somebody's talking to
well I kind of wish comedy would kind of
get back to like the rich of Pride and
Bill Cosby you know back then if you was
a comedian you had some type of talent
anybody can be a comedian now I mean
literally you're a [ __ ] assistant if
you want to be like my partner in crime
well he just get on stage and you know
do whatever and I see it all the time
and you know sometimes I ask myself Joey
I said well I am I'm too real cuz you
know the [ __ ] that happened to me they
think it's supposed to only happen to a
man I get up that's on my [ __ ] muffle
the shot man in here and it wasn't his
fault it's my fault because I dunks well
I wait I'm like oh my god you you would
be surprised how many white women want
to cry gonna leave me alone [ __ ] I
don't want to cry this [ __ ] is funny you
buy a t-shirt and get the [ __ ] out of my
line cuz I ain't crying about this [ __ ]
I don't got time to be crying life is
too short you know take take take your
cousin and play them the way you wanna
play them you I mean you can make it out
of a pity party or you can make it out
of a real party life to me is all about
get up get out and get something ain't
got time to be crying about a
[ __ ] time especially nothing
that happened to me at 86 I don't give a
[ __ ] if it happened yesterday I'm
turning it into something positive
and I think that's what a lot of people
you know a lot of comedy they think a
lot of you know young people think they
comes they just go home stage and talk
about anything
me personally I don't want to hear that
about you can't get no [ __ ] I don't
want to I want to hear something that I
can remember you buy a lot of
[ __ ] in this club tonight can't
get no [ __ ] I don't want to hear that
about you suck dick a lot of [ __ ]
suck dick I don't suck because I got
vertigo but back in the day I tried this
[ __ ] it ain't for me it's too much work
it is I mean I want to hear some real
[ __ ] I want to hear some real comedy and
you know that's where I think we a lot
of people were [ __ ] offended easily
to now yeah I tell him go [ __ ] yourself
I had one lady in Canada damn near
wanted oh she wouldn't stop crying like
looking at [ __ ] going on over that son
well I've got a cushy crotch she's like
cuz I told the stories about on you know
how I was shot a [ __ ] touch
being a dingaling man or whatever I tell
you know sometime I just call Frank this
ain't even no joke I was telling about
my kid's father how are we so different
in aging you call it child molestation
but I call him let's make a deal how are
you my daddy touch me I got [ __ ] to do
about your daddy planning your [ __ ]
man you need to talk to your counselor
you get on this [ __ ] I'm not your
counselor [ __ ] get the [ __ ] away from
me I don't do counseling don't get on
away from that she'd go write you a book
I'm trying to write me a book too [ __ ]
gonna write a book about your dad hand
up your ass and get over it hey man you
can do anything like you can go back
there he didn't leave his hand in your
ass is it hurting you when then get over
and do something about it
write a books or other little girls
don't get their hands stuck up they'd
add a hand stuck up nay I don't hear
your problem I got my own [ __ ] prop
I'm not [ __ ] Light beer dude [ __ ] drop
the leak I'm psychologically you're not
even stoned and you're stumped I think I
might soon let me give some shoutouts
here
Armando so God Oh Jerry Henson Gabriel
mo Gaza
Jim drug unison wait for dusk our bar
Ted Lynch and Louis BR ba whatever your
[ __ ] name is
my family you [ __ ] kill me right
there I love it I love having [ __ ]
controversy I'm this [ __ ] people
at home sweating bullets right now it's
a Sunday night people get shot in the
head
on it for all your [ __ ] needs you
understand me any Newton nutrients
supplements whatever the [ __ ] you need
on it calm they got it going on there
main thing is the alpha brain on a
percent guaranteed you'll be running on
all [ __ ] cylinders you
understand me go to a nice calm and
press on what Lee church Church CH you
are CH get 10% off you'll put on the
lift they got to stay on a program they
got kettlebells on that's got so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on to get that
digestive enzymes now I'm waiting on
them so I can tell you guys how I feel
most Popeye ends I think that the pie
ends on my I'm hope they are I could
they just tremendous I'm hearing that
they have the the testosterone pylons
[ __ ] working for a lot of people some
guys sent me some emails but the only
way to find out is to go to on it give
it a shot
Columbus did right what the [ __ ] go
press it in and see what they send you
also on the list today some of my
favorite [ __ ] people right here is my
main [ __ ] Hulu Plus
I love Hulu Plus you understand me and
I'm gonna tell you why you go watch
scandal The Daily Show Modern Family you
can watch on your Smart TV your computer
your Roku Apple TV Xbox Playstation you
can also get access to original you
can't get nowhere else and you can binge
on [ __ ] 10 episodes of anything 12
episodes whatever the [ __ ] you want what
we do in church is at $7.99 a month but
you get two weeks for free $7.99 a month
is like a [ __ ] quarter a day you
understand me but because you remember
the church you get two weeks for free so
when you go order right after this
[ __ ] podcast one of they press the
box leave Joey Joey in the [ __ ] hulu
plus J 0 ey understand they ain't
[ __ ] around Hulu Plus calm go to the
box and press what jelly oh [ __ ] it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
$7.99 a month and [ __ ] free for two
weeks you get to give this shot who does
that
when was the last time you gave somebody
crackling said sample it for two weeks
and come back nobody does that
[ __ ] HuluPlus does that type of [ __ ]
also fathers days coming why [ __ ] around
Dollar Shave Club they got a dollar six
dollars and a nine dollar package I mean
what the [ __ ] why you're gonna go for
bells and whistles it's got a [ __ ]
remote control it's got a stethoscope
who needs us all you need is a [ __ ]
razor to shave your [ __ ] face hit
clean and smooth you understand me way
before that junk why be a [ __ ] Mook
like the rest of these people and spend
$2,000 for this or $100 a month and
razors who [ __ ] cool Dollar Shave
Club got it going on $1.00 six dollars
or nine dollars you understand me for
the year nine thousand one times 12
that's what why don't we wanna wait for
[ __ ] a year that's the smoke most
people spend every three months on
[ __ ] raises you don't believe me go
down go down to the [ __ ] store wait
on line like the [ __ ] and a half a month
and when you get there yelling oh Jesus
Joey was correct he's taking [ __ ]
care of me he's looking out for me
that's a [ __ ] true soldier so go to
Dollar Shave Club go to the box and
press Church there you go Dollar Shave
Club slash [ __ ] wizard slash calm
Church whatever is gonna Joey Diaz I'm
then get your [ __ ] together you gonna be
happy
not only that they got a post [ __ ]
workout a pre-shave pointment they got
some [ __ ] things you wipe your
[ __ ] will not turn one wipe Charlies
really at that type of action
shaving they keep your balls in oil and
your wife to use it who's better than me
also escape pod tank common ain't
[ __ ] around the month of [ __ ] June
okay off the [ __ ] chain the numbers
they're doing this month they're [ __ ]
tremendous call Jeremy 1-800 number he's
always got [ __ ] answers rightly he
always answers the phone he'll hook you
up just get the [ __ ] just a tank
model you're gonna save thousands any
tank they got industrial commercial
residential you're gonna save a couple
[ __ ] Gino toilet you know why cuz
that's how escape about that tank escape
pod tank comm works go to escape pod
tank calm right now
don't [ __ ] around see what they got
maybe you want to get a flotation device
for your house you fill it up with Epson
saw your washing aren't you going to
smoke a half a number
and you can see your future who needs a
[ __ ] squeegee boy little [ __ ] you
need go to escape pod tank calm if you
get something mentioned Joey peers get
$250 well but just the tank my leading
models you get $150 off right now you
know save thousands go to escape pod
tank calm my [ __ ] around also this
weekend I'm gonna be a [ __ ] Governors
Thursday Friday Saturday all freak shows
I don't even know where the [ __ ]
different towns they're about well a
Belford [ __ ] this that levee town is
Saturday the one place is Friday in the
other place is Thursday if you're not go
to Governors calm see what they got also
the shirts are in the patches are in the
mugs are in my [ __ ] around gonna Joey
Diaz dotnet that your tour dates patches
t-shirts do what the [ __ ] you got to do
you sexy [ __ ]
can you breathe I stopped talking just
in case I need to give you a sepm I used
to be a fake as medical since I did a
little bit of everything you gotta play
a couple [ __ ] different times yeah
one thing I won't do is sell Buzzi Jo
that she'd have gone ain't no value to
selling that [ __ ] man I love you thank
y'all so much for having me
where you at this weekend were you at
the next couple weeks um go to my
website I know I'm playing Lafayette
theatre in September I'm okay I don't
know my website comedian miss Pat is
Miss Pat comedy calm Twitter and
Facebook I can't [ __ ] remember Joe
I'm over 40 I can barely see it's
[ __ ] you're in Montana Missouri Lake
oh sorry yeah I'm there on the 16th
you're on deja boo' comedy club yeah
16th and 19th telling them and the funny
bone and dating on the 20 that's a
special night John each other come out
and support me because I really want
this club to start giving me an
opportunity what was that ah dating
funny bond what night it's a Thursday
night is especially the one white gold
July July 24th of July go see it you got
some [ __ ] heavy dude
he had a life man that's why comedy
comes easy it's easy for you next eight
you were doing before was hard
this shit's [ __ ] like stealing yeah
yeah well my stays and tell people your
life and connect with them you're
beautiful you know well thank you black
this [ __ ] they say when they was like
you have a female Joe at the end I pull
you up I was like we just shape the line
we don't look alike
[ __ ] quantifier about a little Chaka
Khan a nobody
for my girl miss bad that's how I
[ __ ] run it tonight it's a special
Sunday night edition you know miss
pallets I'm happy you came on so he made
me think a lot of [ __ ] tonight they made
me think of drugs and [ __ ] how lucky
I am to have my wife because she said
this you know it's amazing that the lat
I'd never like after like nine months I
was dating I'm like this ain't gonna
work this poor girl she gonna figure out
I'm a [ __ ] bum she never figured it
out man cuz you never was a bomb the
cars you did car people dealt you in to
make you believe it you know whatever
you went through a lot of times people
can see through all that [ __ ] you
know you can tell when a [ __ ]
come over your house and steal your DVD
player right that [ __ ] said to me one
night she goes we were dating like eight
months one night she goes you know and I
tase them I can actually tell you mom's
my mom died and that freaked me out
because I grew up with a lot of people
never said that to me is this little
white girl from Tennessee and figured me
out you know and that [ __ ] up my head
for months and it made me hate it but
love at the same time you know but I'm
happy I stayed and I'm happy you stayed
because I know yeah your doubts at times
but how I did but you know [ __ ] knows
and that's what I hope you [ __ ]
learn the lessons I wasn't bugging shot
ahead and nipples fell off it it was
about smoking no matter how many times
you get knocked down who gives a [ __ ]
they can't stop you know like a man
that's what they want to do they want to
stop and they want you to become a group
groper and you want they want you to
tell people to feel sorry from [ __ ] that
noise you [ __ ] either rose beef
sandwich you scratch your nuts you smell
your [ __ ] fingers and [ __ ]
shoot-'em-up I don't know where I just
saw you stretching your nuts
smell and it to me they smell like roast
beef I would [ __ ] around salmon it's
nine o'clock I took a shower like is six
oh my balls
we'll be back tomorrow morning at 6 a.m.
with the doctor given us some health
advice tomorrow as [ __ ] like that was
something usually say I'd drop it on it
nothing is tomorrow and maybe if you got
tomorrow's Lee's debut again we got
about a hundred and forty four Green
Hornet's Lee's gonna [ __ ] go with the
Iranian government they go a hundred
days straight like that movie for some
movie when what's-his-name goes over and
saves the prisoners oh yeah how many
days where the prisoners over I have no
idea like 144 you have a [ __ ] magic
you know do edibles 444 [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you you're a soldier a Jewish [ __ ]
tank that's that you are you bad
[ __ ] get the little blue
matching this shirt up there the Israeli
flag I will be back tomorrow 6 a.m. hit
me thank you Miss bad I love you stay
barking music well I can't change okay
oh yeah okay
I can change my hairdo you would not my
color
now that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial ooh plus
Google Plus as you binge on thousands of
hit shows anytime anywhere on your TV PC
smartphone or tablet support this
podcasting and an extended free trial of
Hulu Plus when you go to Hulu Plus
complex Joey or go to Joey Diaz dotnet
and click on the Hulu Plus banner
don't forget to sign up for Dollar Shave
Club comm get high-quality razors sent
to your door every month from
fractionally pay at retail now go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash church
or just go to Joey Diaz done and click
on the dollar chef lebanner
and thank you to escape our 10.com go
there for just the tank model save $150
[Music]